This is Suzie. I copy.
-Suzie!
-Dusty-bun?
"Dusty-bun"?
Where have you been?
I'm so, so sorry.
I-- I've been really busy...
uh, trying to save the world
from Russians and monsters.
[chuckles] Of course you have.
Get the goddamn number already!
Who was that?
[stammers] It was...
Uh, I don't know, actually.
I think it was just some interference.
So, why don't we, uh, change frequency
to 14.158?
Copy that, shifting frequency. Standby.
[radio whines]
[panting]
-[Suzie] Dusty-bun, you copy?
-[Dustin] I copy, Suzie-poo.
It sounds much better now, thanks.
-[both] Suzie.
-Okay, so, listen,
do you know Planck's constant?
Do you know the Earth orbits the sun?
[snickers] Okay, so I know it starts
with two sixes, and then a...
W-What is it?
Okay, let me just be clear on this.
I haven't heard from you in a week,
and now you want a mathematical equation
that you should know
so you can... save the world?
Suzie-poo, I promise,
I will make it up to you
as soon as possible.
You can make it up to me now.
-What?
-I want to hear it.
-Not right now.
-Yes, now, Dusty-bun.
Suzie-poo, this is urgent.
Yes, yes, you're saving the world,
I heard you the first time,
but Ged is also saving Earthsea
and he's about to confront the shadow,
so this is Suzie, signing off.
Wait, wait, wait! Okay.
Okay. Okay.
Shit.
[sighs]
♪ Turn around ♪
♪ Look at what you see ♪
♪ In her face ♪
-♪ The mirror of your dreams ♪
-[synth music playing]
[Suzie and Dustin harmonize]
♪ Make believe I'm everywhere ♪
♪ Given in the light ♪
♪ Written on the pages is ♪
♪ The answer to ♪
♪ A never-ending story ♪
[Suzie and Dustin vocalizing]
♪ Reach the stars ♪
♪ Fly a fantasy ♪
[singing sounds on radio]
♪ Dream a dream ♪
♪ And what you see will be ♪
♪ Rhymes that keep their secrets will ♪
♪ Unfold behind the clouds ♪
♪ And there upon a rainbow is ♪
♪ The answer to a never-ending story ♪
[Suzie and Dustin vocalizing]
♪ Story ♪
[chuckles]
Planck's constant is 6.62607004.
[panting]
[keypad beeps]
You just saved the world.
[sighs]
Gosh, I miss you, Dusty-bun.
And I miss you more, Suzie-poo.
I miss you more,
multiplied by all the stars in our galaxy.
[Dustin] No, I miss you--
Enough.
[static hissing]
[ominous synth music playing]